what's up everybody happy Tuesday
Persia here max is joining me of course
because we got that apex legends action
poppin off the fight or fright event has
begun the halloween themed goodness for
everyone who loves their spooky season
no it's actually crazy
they have jump scares in shadow fall and
it's terrifying man I've definitely
gotten scared multiple times yeah if you
have a rakhna phobia you're gonna have a
bad time for sure yeah so yeah the new
limited event for fight and/or frights
is shadow fall and it's kind of a mix of
Apex mixed with like halo zombies mixed
with some left for dead cuz it has like
all this stuff going on and it's pretty
cool so uh we're just going to show off
some of the events like collectibles and
skins and stuff real quick and then
we're gonna see if max can survive one
game and I got like one kill and after
that it was it was really tough he like
towards like the second half of the game
there's so many zombies and there's like
so little of you guys and your guys are
against each other still sorry it's not
even like a team effort just like it's a
complete fee for all it's really tough
these are really cool got a little
jack-o'-lantern charm now yeah awesome
pretty cool watching scanner hiss uh
facie makes is really cool that's like
perfect with the skin yeah
they stay giving live one the best skins
I'm not mad at it I'm happy about it I'm
just saying she has all the best songs
yeah she does that some pretty cool
skins Hallows Eve that's pretty cool for
some reason it might be the lighter end
of the gun skin uh let's see we also got
more banners all I said I'll go very
well with his costume that he gets -
this one's super cute you can't really
zoom in on se but it's like
trick-or-treating I see you like
Halloween it's so cute I get the little
trick-or-treat bag is not super cute God
feel oh I like that that's pretty cool
what else
spit not too bad that's some nightmare
for Christmas yeah it's about to say
some some Tim Burton going on you Bates
pretty cool I like it I like moving
patterns addition and now the gold stuff
is the legendary stuff here this is
pretty cool
that's nice apparently supposed to match
with wraiths skin because she's a good
witch but I feel like I should have been
like a broom mistake yeah that looks
like the Hat yeah like definitely like a
kind of a broom flick the trip will take
there all his all the cards are good
tear although they had a missed
opportunity and turning his drone into a
baton oh that would have been really
good when I first saw this skin I was
like man yeah and oh they should have
made equip like what is a man a
miserable pile of secrets oh my gosh
that's pretty cool - so funny on brand
Raj is a legendary skins are pretty cool
- well that's part of as a holo oh yeah
I thought it was like something related
with the costume yeah that's pretty cool
too kind of creepy though is that a
heart oh it's a heart Oh
anaphase zombie peace
creepy alright this is probably my
favorite city the entire thing yeah this
is so cool bloodhounds also slowly
becoming my second to third yeah yeah
I've been playing him a lot more he's
like you can see like his tree chest
yeah it's pretty great alright and then
I got this like rooster tail looking
Mastiff with the jaw yeah that's pretty
cool actually the boomstick lot going on
there
wingman skin it's pretty cool oh cool I
see I seen that yeah it's got like the
clown face fire-breathing clown yeah I
first I was like what here's a
Frankenstein Gibby
big boy looking very good I like the
shield yeah evil vibe I'm not huge it's
cool yeah definitely like Wicked Witch
of the whichever side yeah it's really
good yeah if you're an it fan this is
like the one creepy bit yeah I mean
that's definitely a festive fits the
mood um happy hour asks is there any
good skins where Watson they do have one
Halloween skin yes it changes colors
it's just a reskin this is the reviled
right oh that goes with Rogers yep
that's cool too that they made like
weapons to match the skins oh I love
this one actually saw pictures of this
one yeah it's got like a tiki hut feel
yeah I got that what is it Dave the dead
oh yeah Dave Dennis right Coco vibes so
yeah this is Watson skin yeah you could
see like the bats under cool costume
change colors a little bit yeah very
festive
alright of course and in the air loom if
you ever gonna get that that's pretty
cool and it's also yeah again like life
lines thing the gift she's running along
like you can see her animation she's
actually kind of like air drumming and
she's running so if he actually had
these heirloom
guessing that you'll kind of actually
have that drumsticks with you to do that
with as times okay let's drop it yeah
let's give it a go yeah I'm gonna try
not to get jumpscared this apply grease
man it's so cruel because I love looting
in supply crazy and the fact that they
turn them into jump scares I don't like
this so if you guys don't know the
shadow fall I've been it starts with
like 32 or something people 35 and then
once you get down to the last remaining
10 that you guys form a squad and you
got to make it to a dropship and escape
but if you die you turn into a zombie or
like a shadow I guess is what they are
calling them yeah so the shadows get
like more powerful beatdown they run
faster but they have less life and you
can respawn as many times as you want
yeah I think respond as many times as
you want until the dropship is on the
ground I think I never actually in it
wait you know we should probably figure
I'll figure that out yeah cuz as far as
I can tell when I was playing I could
just die as many times as I wanted to it
just keep it one passage yeah I know
that I definitely did that a bunch of
time and then I think the very last game
I played it was like I was trying to
chase down somebody who was running
towards a ship and they kills me and
then I couldn't drop anyone I don't know
yeah I was just spectating so we'll see
that's kind of silly and you got the
Leviathans glowing in the dark
nighttime Kings Canyon all right I'm
gonna try a drop here that's right I
can't ping yeah
that's the other thing feels like no
pinging I did befriends someone in a
game I played earlier I kind of heard
them running up on me site just started
crouching up and down they could see us
being friendly cuz it was like I think
the last 11 people so I was like no
let's be friends and then kind of
strategize your teamwork yeah but we
still ended up getting dead interesting
is I guess this is the first time that
the charged rifle is on Kings Canyon now
oh yeah that's right I did see it one
match that I played and pick it up
though I was scared I was like this
seems like an automatic weapon type of
game yeah I guess Brandon said I'll Tony
during extra life stream if we finally
see Eric Tate on stream again well he's
out on vacation right now let him enjoy
his vacation hopefully when he comes
back he might have some extra time yeah
and he's also very busy and a very
important person in this office alright
it begins we already have three shadows
so I'll let the Chad decide if they want
me to go as spicy or they want me to try
it away spicy you're a win guys I feel
like I've tried a few different ways
like I tried one match I was like okay a
run-and-gun
try to be optimal and get as close to
you know where I'm supposed to be when
the dropship comes yeah died because all
the shadows start hovering around where
the dropship lands when it starts coming
in right so then I tried the opposite I
was like okay I'll hide until it lands
and then I'll run over there and I had a
wraith and I tried to save my portal
from when it the ship was on the ground
so I could use my portal to get to it
you know trying to be all right hacker
like they smacked me out of my portal
while I was well I was you know do using
it so I was like oh man bummer how does
a bummer but yeah I only played a few so
far so I'm sure there are more
strategies
max'll saying he's used caustic but he
didn't have caustic on this couch no I
don't really have a that's a local
dragon oh yeah see at this plane there's
just too many legends in the Oh too many
legends to you know be friends just yet
so like 23 people alive oh if only you
had another good name can't believe
they're gonna nerf the charged rifle
already did they charge nerf it already
I don't or I didn't think I don't think
it's act like live yet but I saw that
they mentioned it in their dev talk
video yeah don't blame nerfs are on the
way I feel like I heard so many people
complaining about that gun here very
well on these headsets let me turn it up
a little yeah oh yeah it's coming up
it's a different guy before it went off
all right so we're gonna shadow down
what's this that's where you died so you
can let go right back to where they
asked you which was happening to me a
lot and I was kind of like that's why
but I think it's random on the direction
you drop in every time because you saw
right there you were pretty far so you
couldn't really get back there right
away I was like drop six miles an hour
really fast I think the top speed going
straight down to 150 waters
she said oh yeah I'm not very good at
this game
figure out where they are
I saw a marker over here somebody
getting killed yeah so if it's red that
means your fellow shadow dive if it's
white that means you converted someone
yeah there's someone over there
200 200 plus meters away seems like when
you're a legend and you're killing
people you gotta move really quick yeah
cuz they know where you are can't stop
to loot for too long and the shadows are
just super fast so they're really like
hard to outrun all those are kind of
cool like oh yeah you can climb like
anything almost like all the way up a
wall oh really yeah that's cool okay I
like this hard time finding anybody I
know you're almost down to the top ten
hello elite game resin silver magma
welcome to the street can I
every time you jump your zombie leg or
your shadow you can knock down doors in
one hit oh really
alright so now you guys see there's like
a hundred seconds until this evacuees
action drops right which is a ton of
time yeah so what I noticed everybody
doing is they go to where this ship is
gonna drop and then from there they just
wait to see like who's killing their
friends well magma if you're bad at
Battle Royale this is like this kind of
battle royale but not as straight up the
original modes so at least I'll get to
respawn as a shadow what do you guys do
for Halloween
obviously it changes as you get older
but I really do miss going
trick-or-treating click on here on adult
you don't go to the doors for buy door
to get candy just go to grocery store
and get the same games a legend but even
if just one legend makes it onto the
ship the legends one really yeah oh it's
just one
I've actually been in two games so far I
think two out of the five I got a chance
to play where the legends won
but it was only ever one person that
needed
and I think it's alleged makes it into
the ship even if the white shadows run
into the ship themselves they can't kill
it oh is they used invincible yeah so
it's not like you know they have nine
seconds and he's like defending the
inside of the ship like you're in you're
in you're good to go
yes they lost because they didn't
still victorious shadows the whole
zombie squad I still love that like
Pathfinder he's full screen is still
active even when he is a shadow oh
really
show us a little like oh yeah
what was he was he he was like angry and
sad I guess I would be mm so yeah guys
shadow fall I really like nighttime king
scanning actually oh I just noticed all
the champions in the back being all
shadowy zombies oh yeah cool yeah I
thought like call duty zombies looked
kind of cool but I think these ones like
you look better yeah because when you
shoot the shadow it just yeah to us cuz
I was a cool idea
Thanos yeah although we're the confusing
me as they drop a box for a second that
disappears too
I'm ecstatic my plan is hopefully I can
just tense up an area maybe defend
myself I don't have caustic hmm I wonder
how much damage the fence does to the
shadows I think it does it doesn't kill
them I think it does 20 damage different
team damage so it's not enough to kill
them but them down yeah Mikey said this
is gonna give me nightmares so sleep is
overrated true man we didn't even run
into an infected supply crate yes I'm
really balanced on here so I think this
about buying one of those
Peach's said fun fact my birthday is the
day before Halloween nice so party to
your birthday and then you go crazy
why don't legends work together a young
man
I think though like until he gets for
the last ten it's kind of hard to get
people to have like team up with you
yeah like I only had one person willing
to like befriend me after like shooting
at me at first and noticing I was just
crouching up and down like yeah we were
like at 12 or 11 people left that's
pretty cool and happy early birthday
fishing really like yeah unless you have
a turbocharger I feel like you
definitely don't want an energy weapon
that needs time so you want none this
kind of fight beatdown they're pretty
intense
you can there are like levels like good
shield but I feel like they're really
rare I've only ever picked up level 1 or
level 2 shield but yeah I think they
adjusted the loot for this game type
I feel like definitely if I have the
chance to watch my call a Spitfire
motion was the toilet part really nice
in this situation that's kind of the
go-to strategy with any zombie game is
like any god with a huge mag chesed as
caustic I took 15 shadows with my own
yeah I definitely think that good old
sin the switch is killing it this year
Brandon lots of games coming to switch I
kind of want to see more custom switches
that was kind of a spook and that wasn't
even a spider
like the growl that give me the votes
really loud to wonder if any Miz can
hear that - or is that just a nice
cliche said they use the Gibraltar all
right as they're getting to the dropship
and four of them survive and it like
killed all the boys for you that's
pretty yeah defensive characters are the
way to go on this map definitely need
like jingle or Gibraltar caustic yeah
Gibraltar caustic are amazing Watson I'm
not sure about these fences because
right Chad that scared me too that's
like the third time I've seen it it's
not even like new to me but still
terrifying oh man looks like I'm not
gonna fight that cuz it's on high ground
yeah
I want to make at least one game I
played with top tanks I haven't even
gone to top ten yet whenever you get to
see your other squad members and see
what they are
once you go so top ten it like has a
banner pop up and it says final tune and
then everyone gets like a little white
icon above them you can see where they
are it's crazy though cuz you get
knocked down like one hey if you don't
have a good shield's right and then it
does give you the option to revive your
team but there is no way yeah yeah
exactly
it's pretty crazy I mean this is also
coming from me who's bad and only played
a couple game stuff I'm sure if you're
super good at this game you can buddy
just you know clear all all the zombies
and then pick up your friend but I don't
know they might just search them and set
a chance I think the strategy to get top
10 with this game type just because you
see like all those pings from like
enemies shooting each other and the guys
dying like just don't do anything
because then you don't get paint I have
been personally escaped but I made it to
top 10 and then one of my people escaped
so we like technically yeah and I just
spectated the rest of the match just to
see like I'm gonna make a safe high goal
I wonder if
I wonder if Bob finder uses the beacon
and it tells you where the dropship is
dropping to that would probably be
really smart
that would be kind of cool does this
require an update yes it does but it's
not very big it's pretty quick
I think the update was already
incorporated the last charge rifle yep
all right we're looking good right now
got shield that's not level one I've got
luck
that's just the Leviathan
now Watson's all it seems pretty useless
in this yeah the zombies aren't gonna be
throwing grenades at you anyways you
don't write your shield yeah you should
get to throw down a bunch of fences
though yes
hopefully this dropship
[Music]
[Applause]
yes allomere this is Kings Canyon but
it's the nighttime version so it's cool
that we got both worlds edge and Kings
Canyon now cuz I can go back to a little
edge still so it's nice we have that
option to go back and forth now oh okay
so yes Sartain so now you can see all
this on me oh yeah the white oh the
white oh I kind of teammates and then
obviously he just told on me there's a
saw and he dropped so it's always
difficult it's like do I meet up with
the squad or no you just gotta try this
[Music]
goose down rest in peace
scary just see they're like landing and
running everything when you start to a
like group up though I feel like fade
that's part of it yeah you might have
helped but then again at the same time
it might be oh that's the way to go it's
over there oh I'm I try to be with them
although I might get marks on the
dropship is dropping here right you see
the yellow icon yeah woo they have high
ground which is great for them but like
potentially really bad cuz all these
zombies gonna drop is that robot of the
ring
oh Jesus oh yeah zombies can ride
zipline all that work to get up there
yeah
wait did you heal Oh in Jersey
can you get knocked down shield that's a
good question fees whoa if you thought
zombies were scary which Lacy's zag
laggy zombies all these the most
terrifying them all
oh okay so I'm sort of I thought like
that they said one legend wins one
legend goes from the perspective that's
the dead teammate oh I was dead and then
they got onto the ship and then after
they escaped I said I won so I guess if
you're alive okay it doesn't count as
then you lose interesting we're learning
as we go
yeah there's definitely a couple unique
things about this I kind of like being a
zombie I kind of rather prefer more
exciting yeah it's more exciting it's
like more relaxed to because you know
like constantly on edge the entire time
yeah Brian we're not playing in the same
lobby
I'm just spectating while max please
because it is a solo moment yeah to solo
mode the slips that I raged so alright
at this mode I don't believe you there
are a few times
so
like there's no way and we definitely
want to use Gibby but we don't own him
on this console oh no yeah we do
oh wait oh it's costing a lot well try
keep you next game yeah someone with a
good like like area control yeah like
Pathfinder could be good just to like
send the zip line to the ship towards
the end yeah it'll be a nice
all right
I feel like you could have made it to
that dropship
I couldn't fit up to although their
world waters area oh man classic gamers
wants you to struggle because he said
play with crypto there was if there was
a champ I would say the most useless in
this mode it might be that yes no
teammates to relay your penguin no voice
acting yeah he's so late creepy yeah and
shadowy sounding actually you know what
let's see if I can find myself in point
hammer points will take out a zombie on
his enemy shields oh yeah that's true
Dennis said trioxide octane is good for
outrunning the zombies oh yeah he's
about the same speed probably Shane to
run and he totally ran into the wall
now get out of there because you know
you drop it right on you
how's Natalie she's in our game digi
stream okay you gotta find us so you can
team up and make it to the drop ship it
would be a serious feels bad moment if
you just killed all right please say let
us know where you're gonna be like post
it up and then we'll come and try to
like find you so we could hold down the
fort I'd be totally down with that which
is also totally cheating so - please
don't ban us they'll come to kill us we
got to make it out alive together clear
today he's like I'm coming looks like a
30-second delay from I like flinch a
little bit everything I started opening
them from the back end max range
okay cliche is playing a Gibby
okay what area in the map are you 30
seconds ago cliche you want to come to
the farm it's like up here right we'll
be in the farm for at least like I'm 30
seconds to a minute yeah it's gonna be
looking around here for a hammer point
think so dude I really want a hammer
point like Superbad I don't get one
[Music]
what's up me I also feel like certain
healing items are totally useless
because you just don't have enough time
to use it if it really gets him you talk
about like communicate or something yeah
like the three shield batteries some
stuff actually might be more help
especially the thermite I know right
back to the walls oh my god he
disappeared cliches are there Messiah
died
oh oh now they know where we're gonna be
well they better Jordan in the chat so
don't lose max don't bring dishonor to
the office I mean already lost twice so
yes
classic classic praising the Jack
Phoenix is useless this mode
specifically if you have like eight
zombies on you good luck getting that
that is super good because it slows them
down a little bit I mean if you want ray
go drop into this game get surrounded by
like I don't know eight to ten zombies
and then try to use your Phoenix skin
let me know how that works out because
it won't now if we just need the drop
ship to land like right outside this
building it we could just like run out
and get into yeah W flipped a nice setup
we're pretty like far over on the edge
now unified demon
all right cliche you gotta try to you
got excited stream snipe again so we
could team up and have some bacon
[Music]
um Nate asked is this game a better
version of for tonight it kind of just
depends on like how you like to play
like when I tried to play for tonight I
thought I was cool I was just so bad at
building and when I play Peters I kind
of just went and likes run-and-gun
instead of build but I also know people
who are really good at apex I mean at
fortnight for that reason like they're
phenomenal builders and then they just
use that to outplay everybody I
definitely can't build so it depends on
your style I kind of like this cuz it's
like it was fast it felt faster than pub
G to me and then it also didn't have
like the other thrill of building like
Fright Night
and this is coming from someone who was
like at once convinced I'd never get
into a battle royale game ever yeah I
thought I hated all about a rails till I
ran to this one
[Music]
I like the Bell when the round starts
and boy here can't tell if it's a shadow
work oh wait you're the last one oh okay
of course heck yeah toxic I really like
the costumes to actually watch this
container pathline
Arius good lamb-like write on it and
practically Oh midnight said what is
stream sniping so basically it's like
you could you see that we're searching
for a game and then you'll search at the
same time and try to like get into our
lobby and then either killed us or you
guys can be nice and join our team
they're gonna team up with us
I don't want to wait down here
I get stranger things vibes from the
music in this yeah some people if it's
only landed up there's let up
all you made it
all right well
I think have to jump into jump into it I
don't know I've never even gotten that
close so I honestly I'll give you a
fresh sub if you say I love you all
okay so what kind of sub but you're
gonna subscribe where you're gonna go to
subway and get me a fresh sub cuz I'm
down with either or it's all I like
sandwiches I guess I don't know I mean
Subway's like pretty good when you want
like a cheap deal sometimes they have
those like $3 like $6 plea I'm more of a
jack-in-the-box or anything
people are talking to hang me for that
right I love jack-in-the-box in and out
not so much I you know what people hype
it up to me and then I tried it and I
was respecting your life the greatest
burger of all time yeah
I think that it partially why next game
will try octene how would a robot turn
into a shadow I know right really and
his little screen still works
sure thing about giving shield is sort
of useless after system it's meant to
block bullets right but honestly just
melee you right through it yeah so it's
kind of like I leave to have a shield
yeah I got a coach that actually blocks
again two attacks
go
also I noticed that the labs are gone
North elapses between there
oh yeah they were like no I just want to
be a zombie go
I feel like there's not the zombies
gonna get super super powerful until
there's like a good amount
aji Grimes this is the brand-new shadow
fall event and it just came out today
it's a part of the fight or fright event
the Halloween themed event for apex and
it's pretty fun little spooky midnight
we already told you what Street sniper
was you missed it you wasn't paying
attention stay on your toes grow a skin
thou shalt receive damn this area's
fantastic can you be a shadow instantly
not really but we did see one someone
just like fly off of the map and like
basically off themselves so that's that
was probably because they wanted to be a
shadow yeah the strats pick up that
sheet
what happens when you're not focused
that's okay we wanted to be a shadow
inning
yeah yes you definitely drop in in
random directions to drop in super close
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we got our event
oh I'm gonna try this oh you know what
the strata is I should probably drop
flow until I season
definitely people
yeah for sure oh he's outside Hugh you
know he got freaked out
cuz the second he got up there dang that
was crazy
don't worry does this affect your kill
death ratio because this is Omni
impunity
[Music]
piqué got you good yeah for sure
[Music]
do shadows take damage from the zone no
oh I actually don't know I don't think
so bunny hopping zombies sound of any
high four deaths stranding climb up that
wall yes 99 oh I did see the box you're
right
serpentine patterns
[Music]
whoever them oh this is the third party
right here boo come on buddy are you
gonna do what you gonna do what no where
our fellow shadows at you guys are still
against each other cliche a few stream
snape us again we gotta meet up and then
make it to the dropship I don't think
you lost image from running to the rock
I think you like a stray bullet or
something
[Applause]
[Music]
I wonder if the more people are shadows
the stronger they become not really it
looks like the health and stuff
although I feel like I think the legends
do regain home
you can't land in the hot zone we don't
ah ha ha it's so powerful oh my god
they're all together now right the top
side
yep they're officially a
[Music]
these guys yeah I just go straight to
the evac zone go straight here it's
really the only way to do it yeah yeah
this guy's got the rats too
I know we got to get a little sprout
back on the stream risen row new name
watched our fellow shadow toll we missed
the jump
where's the thing coming she was gonna
be like right here yeah
I can't actually see what's gonna land
J Briella said winning as a legend in
this game mode it's literally being a
guy seems like oh god oh wow way over
there
you cannot play this mode and squads
Leslie although I wish you could it's
just so lonely dropping in and like oh
they're always trying to land on it
cheater
oh I guess Oh interesting that's not as
hard as I thought it you just have to
get within that green ring I guess
huh
it needs to be some adjustments
I would say something that I think
should be a thing is like if you're in
the ship and like they can kill you yeah
yeah you can't kill them yeah I don't
know that seems too forgiving last I
thought you had to actually like climb
into the JumpShip that I thought too
yeah but seems like it just got touch it
yeah I saw him just like jump from the
top like into the ring those green dots
and yeah he was in there so that's
interesting maybe it's not as well it's
still hard actually but all right let it
start it's like trying to climb into
something and getting my cave line
no I am NOT playing I'm just spectating
right now because it's a solo mode and
usually when we do play apex though
we're in the same game but here try now
octane
so when we were dropping let's drop to
water treatment if you actually are the
same game I'm gonna go to water treat
yeah yeah people are definitely just
killer
oh yeah hi my name is Persia and this is
max
yeah I realize we only have our names
with
so if you join in the middle of the
street
make it to see them showing up now
sudanese turned around and a bunch of
weapons passed to you Oh somebody's here
I think so
Sneaky's kind of wanted this win one
fight here
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah that's weird actually
I wonder if it happens that way in this
this way you can pick it up quickly
all right size doesn't come back to try
it oh yeah just use your speed drugs and
wreck that guy definitely they gave out
that a cliche didn't make it in you're
on your own
um what's my highest rank in this I
actually only just play regular mode
because I'm ice playing by myself and I
don't like playing ranked mode we ran
into one of the spiders yes he did yeah
but really likes also an open one and
earlier when I played I ran into like a
couple zombies and a spider that's
scared every time
Unni
actually you know what grenades are yeah
one final guide the unlimited climbing
of the shadow is super fun yeah I could
just climb anywhere is it actually
unlimited or if it's just like a really
high amount
um it's like a really high mount I think
the place is where they obviously don't
want you to run up to you won't be able
to make it up there
but a lot of the other things okay
although that probably tension I think
it helped that we weren't looking at it
yeah that wasn't that's what I'd like to
do anyways when I'm opening crates
oh he looks so cool I do like the Aria
45 actually not too bad there's a level
three extended mag you can make it work
oh dang Dean said I do think the fact
that they can one-shot with level one
shields is a bit ope I like kind of
agree at least if you have a shield it
should take it we talked about through
the shadow silly kill you oh yeah
but if you have like level twos or above
basically - sure I think it's level 3 or
above it's three shot
I think it's X 75 damage - feels like
he's like right below yeah whoo - I mean
that was really funny because I'm really
awkward situations I thought he heard
you - I think so
you were both being really cautious I
mean it depends the ECD pathfinders I
know
they want the dropship here but I also
like using raids and Bangalore and
lifeline lifeline was like my old
Tremaine for a long time mere Fox this
is the new shadow fall mode for the
Halloween events
yes needs more fences it's look at this
point is a helmet even effective oh man
you got a big drop in like okay
all right let's see how these games
nobody
oh yeah double tap to know thing I'm
like at first I was like men you know a
zombie should be able to damage you when
you're in the ship until it's tickle you
but now looking at it you might be kind
of yeah that would be kind of suck to
like oh I win and then you like ship
that would be like a big heartbreak
exactly all right who do we try next
I was definitely liking Watson but yeah
she doesn't have much of a getaway
driver in that situation she could have
put up like 20 more
don't push the envelope nice you ready I
kind of think that being fast with
Octane's the ability is useful shadows
an overwhelming situation I'm long but
either way like it's gonna have a speed
you'd be dead anyways - yeah yeah mere
Fox it's like halo zombies and left for
dead and apex which is a really cool
combo should I kill myself I cooked up
up the matter
now she might be in our games you know
I'm gonna drop spicy
we have box they have like different
music and then the announcer is a creepy
and spooky ethnics is doing it right it
got some really cool stuff yeah I like
it a lot and if you guys have any
apex devs just did this like video
stream type thing which was pretty cool
actually
and it explained a lot of different
things about the name of season and how
they made Kings Canyon and what's to
come and even merge stuff so they showed
off like old Kings Canyon well I'm gonna
be a zombie this game cuz you were mean
to me you're like getting all the ammo
in the world yeah oh now I got a hammer
point you know what I mean I guess I'm
passively healing but
[Music]
I think it's really funny in that last
situation with that lifeline he ever
warded with a purple shield and donut
happy about being sued though any more
light ammo to Trichy said you were meant
to be a zombie this round Brendan we are
playing on ps4 and at the moment
[Music]
oh man just pick up their shields I
guess oh snap pinball wizard might be in
our game let's team up bro
let's give to this dropship
yeah that creepy feeling like you'd have
to constantly look over your back and
turn around
[Music]
[Music]
I feel like you just need to stay on the
move don't stop anywhere don't try to
hold down the fort just run and run and
she can't run anymore
what time is it for us it is 308 at the
moment which means we're gonna be live
for approximately another 22 minutes or
so so you guys have a few more chances
to stream snape us and get into our game
does anybody know a good way to get into
the same game as my friend honestly you
guys might just have to search at the
exact same time and hope for the best
but it is a solo move so might be kinda
difficult
I see Dean says you're right mobility is
keen esteem so Pathfinder Mirage and
octane are the OG Cooper this one yeah
considering how fast the shadows are
true having some mobility is good some
defenses go to some situations too
you know what would make this really
busted is that if you know you're well I
guess that's why they did it they're not
technically zombies or shadows those the
only headshots all right if you're a
zombie
only a headshot yeah you know like in
movies and stuffs the zombie you gotta
like shoot him in the brain you're like
I think they just take no damage but
just I think they should do that in this
except it would be even more difficult
for the legends to it
ah yeah that's true if you're like 100
meters away and then you use mirages all
the invisibility is super useful
Oh agreed agreed
lots of cool ways it's just an angry
shadow I'm gonna turn the doors into
shadows
[Music]
cute get the link not be moving you're
so fast that if you like move the left
or right stick too much oh he's dancing
up there
Oh
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I go streams of the ship obtain
semi-conscious imply
well they're you
for sure
yeah it's like you have to tip in those
areas they also have Kim
I don't think you can open them shadows
you can lock yourself in but the shadows
can beat down the door in one beat down
man we got to come up with some strats
there's definitely some strats which can
try some Mirage see if that invisibility
works yeah that could come super clutch
in the very end for sure see if you're
gonna trick some zombies into following
your clone could be useful because they
see in like night vision mode too so I
think your your clone like lights up
actually well like highlight I'll show
ya or are we just gonna oh yeah so Fox
said no respawn so you noticed like
right there at the end like whose ship
was already touched down on the ground
and then they killed you but I don't
know if the other two like legends just
so happen to like die it ended so there
was no reason for you to respond anyways
you know yeah what are good guns to run
so we were thinking like LMG something
of a big clip size or maybe like we
should try to find an extended mag as
fast as you can
I think shot is a pretty good severe if
your aim of them I I thought Eva with
DoubleTap someone was using earlier
yes instant zombie mode let's go next
game was going
try to use Watson again
that's probably best identical
yeah it's one of you
I've never done this cool just kind of
funny because people are still landing
and now you're already chasing them down
and overshadow I just might be kind of
college because they have like nothing
basically right man we're coming up with
real strat serious nothing
[Music]
well the way to do this is third party
[Music]
because these guys are gonna fight each
other
one guys over here and one guys over
here unless they team up I mean it's too
early in the game to team up though
that's that guys over there where's
octane though
I'm not sure what a Bob Jones test is
gonna see if I can climb all the way up
watch yo let's go that's so cool oh cool
Dean said jeez seven with double TAS has
a decent sized clip and one shot will
kill with a shadow will kill the shadow
even a body shot oh it's true so that's
pretty good how long is this I've been
gonna be I think it ends on the on
November 1st or 5th like finally they're
gonna fight each other
so far this is not working out you have
to find some fellow shadows roll with
[Music]
oh snap cliches in our game
where you a cliche come to air vase so
we can bring you to the dark side how
much I actually don't know actually I go
slower on a zipline maybe because he run
so fast and they're like normal speed on
the zipline it feels way over there
that's because you're like not even wait
for homeboy actually you know what guess
we're out of ring I don't know if you're
alive or dead he said I'm totally not at
Bunker kosha bunker then we could be
reverse psychology reverse reverse
psychology
even a bad slide jump goes really far I
won't kill you if you won't kill me or
maybe just those ones because I mean you
can't beat it down yeah you just want
your brain oh wow
crack mom you dipped psychological
warfare yes oh there are you is that you
oh oh oh what that was a mirage oh there
is mind yes I went to that wall he must
be in this direction somewhere it can't
be too far out yeah see you
I'm in Borya I was terrifying to be
alleged cuz a zombies and alleged or
both after you
I know until you get to ten ray it's
like there's really no safe place I like
all the candles around the map yeah
extra see on see you cliches and I'm
scared
[Music]
[Music]
Shay died at the tunnels well not your
ride of us movie isn't it it I actually
don't even
it was just such a look I just do
parkour stuff alright
all of us seen in the office if you can
play this mode with a spot I was
definitely in those yeah only just for
that like little bit of communication I
feel like that's what's really making
this difficult fer yes legends like no
King
[Music]
all right so now they're all team go
[Music]
I heard her rape Boyd out next to me
though
Julian's trying to be extra spooky and
get the stream to 666 years
oh boy oh snap but Jesus enemy we're
about to flank that guy and there's
that's okay the guy we were originally
going for him he's one of us
[Music]
Roshan said what upcoming game are you
guys excited about
the new minor word
it's five legends left
[Music]
again
and this is actually working
I know like cars on either side make a
stressful I think where the dropship
lens is also a factor that is true yeah
it's not exactly on like she's somewhat
inactive
okay this gonna be the last game on the
stream who should we be who do we feel
we had the most success with we gotta
close with Watson should actually try
this type of dropping and die yeah the
shadows do remind me of the cod zombies
with the orange eyes a little bit cliche
yeah they're pretty similar looking
wingmen and Eva a yeah that's what I was
thinking too
at least you've a definitely not but
yeah I think I can't hit a wingman shot
worth my life very regular against a 95
mile an hour zombie I don't think we
really want to use Kasich we don't have
them on this profile though I'm an Xbox
boy can try to society bridge me you
might be too late already bro I keep my
squad mates insulated
can we win one game oh we won one game
as a zombie yeah we did we got to see
the whole zombie squad shadow squad
lined up it's so hard not to his
father's on me yeah
crowd one beginning countdown to death
Oh
that's right
yeah definitely dark ball make like 12
inches around you and bunker and watch
the world burn yeah I could do that
also I think bunkers are afraid
oh dang that is pretty creepy Jerry
maybe your house is haunted and the
ghosts wanted to watch apex and wanted
to see everyone get okay
wait what happened Jerry said what I
just got home and this was randomly up
on my computer stupid spider can't you
see were busy here yeah you melt video
all right we're weird shadow now yeah
that either if y'all make it into our
gym yo bro you need to relax
awesome actually
hmm
[Music]
I'm really bad this game hi sorry
this mode is pretty brutal to be fair
it's fun though I like just running
around it so yeah I always like to
octane because that speed boost but it's
like a constant Nathan Ross so the
unlimited climb four walls is probably
the best part I think we're on the same
page there for sure zombies can destroy
the fences oh yeah I think probably just
like scratch down the base of it we said
return to the battlefield yeah silent we
were kind of psyching about that maybe
it's even hot [ __ ] though and you just
like in this moment
which kind of sucks because like his
banner is so cool
see a cliche thanks for joining us I'm
gonna go straight towards that I need to
I need to find somebody
yeah to redeem myself here let's get one
kill I get one kill
let's go scratch somebody we get care
practice coming in another gonna go for
those
it's already been that brain is fun
uh-huh
gotta be sneaky I don't think he's are
you so hard to kill people in this
moment I know zombies like 30% Oh every
time I run through zombie I can't
by anybody anything
I can't kill anybody is a song yeah you
go in with so little life you know as a
as a shadow but you know just like in
movies and stuff it doesn't really get
like too scary for people until there's
like the whole horde is on you to get
into a fight he's like right now I don't
know where to go
best bet is just heading towards the
dropship have you ever won a game of
Legends I technically did I made it a
top ten but then I died and then my
teammates made it in the night somehow
still win I'm like alright I guess
that's the thing it doesn't make any
sense so cuz if you're but if you're
alive my Avengers don't make it to this
[ __ ] then he lose gets that's in
oh boy
you know hey where is everyone says
there's 10 legends sc0 ha ha ha ha
camping and tell your photos shadows
where they are though shadows can't talk
to each other that's a good always like
in the front of the back I'm always
dying first
[Music]
once it landed it said location visible
to all shadows so maybe
I feel like when you were a hero it
filled in videos super accurate points
now the bad partner is trying to know
what are you supposed to do about that
the idea here is fellows got the last
one in my everyone else in the ship
Oh No
oh my god well there you have it folks a
little bit of the new shadow fall event
in the fire Arkwright's the halloween
themed event yeah I know you guys can't
see it but they've just showed like the
last three surrounding people um but
yeah thank you guys for tuning in I know
we had an afternoon stream today we had
some you know downloads difficulties
with overwatch earlier so we didn't end
up playing that but come back tomorrow
we're gonna give it another go and we
stream every morning on weekdays at 11
a.m. Pacific time so feel free to stop
on by we play random things you know no
specific game that we stick to here we
just like to try out what's new and
what's going on so do you like that the
latest and greatest stuff yeah the
latest ingredients like you guys alright
we'll see you guys later have a good one
see ya